تظاهره سوف تنطلق خلال لحظات من هنا من
ساحه الباستي باتجاه ساحه لانسيو الامه
المتظاهرون تجمع هناك اعداد غفيره جدا همم
من كل الاعمار حقيقه لكن الطاغي اليوم في
هذه التظاهره هو الشبان والطلاب هناك نسبه
كبيره منهم لان الدعوه بالاساس صدرت عن
تقريبا 11 منظمه شبابيه تتبع لاحزاب
اليسار وايضا اتمنى هذه الدعوه حزب فرنسا
العصيه الذي يتزعمه
وهذه التظاهره تاتي بعد يومين على تظاهرات
ضخمه جدا عامه فرنسا يوم الخميس الماضي
جمعت نحو مليوني شخص او اكثر من من
مليونين شخص بيحاسب المواطنين هذه
التظاهره هي جزء جزء من تحرك احتجاجي بدا
حقيقه يوم الخميس الماضي بالتظاهر الضخمه
وسيستمر الى الاسابيع المقبله هناك موعد
جديد للتظاهر في
انت همم 31 من هذا الشهر سوف يكون هناك
يوم للتظاهر والاضراب ايضا هذا الاضراب
سوف يستمر ليومين وسوف يكون بعده في
السادس من فبراير ايضا يوم اخر للتظاهر
وايضا للاضراب سيستمر
لثلاثه ايام
متظاهرون الان كما ذكرتهم من شريحه الطلاب
والشبان
ليحتجوا على الاصلاحات التي يقودها الرئيس
الفرنسي في قانون التقاعد رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما لكن ايضا يحتاجون على همم
ارتفاع الاسعار وتدني القدره الشرائيه
وتراجع اوضاعهم كطلاب هناك مشاهد ماساويه
نراها بدنا نراها مؤخرا امام الجامعات
امام المطاعم الجامعيه التي تقدم الوجبات
باسعار مخفضه جدا للطلاب هناك الاف الطلاب
الذين يصطفون على الدور بانتظار ان يحصلوا
على وجبه هذا دليل على مدى سوء حالتهم
واوضاعهم
الاقتصاديه بسبب ارتفاع الاسعار الذي
تسببت في حقيقه الحرب في اوكرانيا وما
تسببت به من زياده في التضخم نسبه التضخم
في فرنسا هي
5.9% هي الادنى في الدول الاوروبيه في كل
الدول الاوروبيه لكن هذا لم يمنع هؤلاء
المتظاهرين من الخروج اليوم الى الشارع
للتمديد بارتفاع الاسعار بالاضافه الى
مساله مساعي الرئيس الفرنسي برفع سنه
التقاعد الى 64 عاما بدلا من 62 عاما خالد